how to turn 100 bucks into a thousand
I'll tell you how to turn zero into a
thousand go to Craigslist where is my
Craigslist video turn off the music avi
honestly I think I just eliminated for
the first time I think I just eliminated
for the first time in my career the
excuse of no money we think a lot about
money and opportunity let me tell you
about an opportunity that I can't get
out of my head this is like a big day
for me
literally for 30 years I've had her like
hey under to that excuse it's over
there's a website called presence calm
under the sales section there's a free
section underneath that where people
list [ __ ] that they want to get rid of
so take it for free cuz most people just
want you to pick it up bigger or what
have you if you happen to actually have
like a truck for like a bigger vehicle
then you are really set if you're broke
grab this and go on the bus the bus like
this everybody look at you be like yeah
yeah keep laughing come home dude
take a picture and then you list it on
Facebook marketplace the arbitrage of
the Internet we see this in retail where
people five things in China post on
Amazon 15 bucks
something's like y'all take your table
ding dong yo hello here you go
and you sell it and when I think about
this I can't I've been dreaming about
this for the last 72 hours by the way
the much more humble version when you
got nothing if you're just sitting like
I need money like all those people ever
like yo can somebody buy me Gary B's
book I can't afford it that means you
know $17 I think it's like $300 a week
make if you take your 6 p.m. to 9 p.m.
Monday and Tuesday picking up [ __ ] and
then be posting it on Facebook my place
and then meeting people on Saturday to
come to your home and grab it and then
somebody's gonna say but damn it to take
40 minutes to go there 40 minutes to
take on the bus tip five minutes to post
seven minutes I'm like what are you
doing with your time anyway you're
laying on the phone going on people's
accounts who are [ __ ] winning saying
this guy's [ __ ] because that's what
you're doing with your time when you're
losing it's crazy to me that the only
thing that stops somebody from winning
is educate
and the work ethic right I understand
that but education comes in so many
different forms go to Craigslist get the
free [ __ ] from the free section take it
and then put on Facebook marketplace and
sell it zero to a thousand Steve zero
thousand